yeah well human-made global warming is
caused by changes in the atmosphere
which are due to burning fossil fuels
primarily as we burn oil gas and coal
this releases carbon dioxide to the
atmosphere and carbon dioxide absorbs
heat radiation from the earth and that
traps the heat radiation and makes the
planet a bit warmer so we notice that
the world has warmed up about one and a
half degrees Fahrenheit in the last
century with most of that warming in the
last 30 years
well there's now 387 parts per million
of co2 in the atmosphere 150 years ago
it was 280 so it's increased by 107 ppm
what we thought a few years ago was that
it would probably be safe to let Co to
go as high as 450 parts per million the
reason we thought that was that we know
that there were previous periods in the
Earth's history called interglacial
periods we're now in a warm interglacial
period which we have been in for about
twelve thousand years but there were
prior periods when the earth was warmer
than it is now and the planet was still
pretty much the way it is now and we
thought that it was then about a degree
or so Celsius which is about two degrees
Fahrenheit warmer than it is now and we
thought that might be okay to be that
warm and 450 parts per million would
probably take us to that sort of a
climate but what we now realize is that
during those prior warm periods sea
level was about six or seven meters
higher than it is now and also we see
what's happening with the current 387
parts per million that's already enough
that the Arctic sea ice is melting
mountain glaciers all around the world
are melting which is going to affect the
freshwater supply for billions of people
the climate zones are shifting so the
Southwest United States and
Mediterranean region are becoming hotter
and drier likewise Australia so you see
increased forest fires and reduced water
supplies in those regions coral reefs
are already under stress they're going
to many of them are going to be lost if
we continue with increasing greenhouse
gases so we realize already the 387 is
actually too large about 350 parts per
million is a more realistic target and
that means we're going to have to phase
out
use of coal over the next couple of
decades if we want to be able to get
back to 350 parts per million
at the fossil fuels we see how much
carbon there is in oil gas and coal and
by far the largest is cold and we know
that we're going to use the oil and the
gas it's very they're very convenient
fuels the big pools are owned by Russia
and Saudi Arabia they're certainly going
to sell that gas and oil if we want to
be able to get back to 350 parts per
million it's this huge coal reserves
that we're going to have to leave in the
ground or we could burn the coal and
capture the co2 and put it back in the
ground but that's very difficult we're
going to have to move beyond fossil
fuels sometime within the next century
anyway so why not do it now and preserve
a climate that will allow our children
and grandchildren to have the same sort
of planet that we enjoy and with all of
the species that are still on the planet